in this video we'll be talking about
Schwan cells which are one type of gal
cells found in the peripheral nervous
system of vertebrates these Swan cells
are really important for myelination of
peripheral nervous system axons they
were first named based on Theodor Swan
who described the swan cells in 19th
century so the key function of the Swan
cell is to myelinate the axons and
thereby cre creating an insulation for
these nerve fibers which would help in
the nerve conduction so this kind of
insulation facilitates the rapid
transmission of neuronal impulse in
myelinating nerve fibers the mine sheet
is not continuous but it is interrupted
in small nodes known as nodes of renva
so due to these nodes of renva the
action potential can literally jump from
one node to another node and this kind
of mode of transmission is known as
salitary transmission of action
potential which further accelerates the
uh nerve conduction and this is only
possible thanks to the swan
cells now let's talk about some other
functions of the Swan cells as well so
Swan cells help in nerve regeneration
nutrient transport and phagocytosis so
in context of nerve regeneration it's
important to note that when there is an
injury in the peripheral nervous system
Schwan cells play key role and they
dedifferentiate and help in the process
of uh neural
regeneration when it comes to nutrient
transport they help in transport of
several nutrients and provide them to
the neurons they can also have
phagocytotic role which might help in
clean up of the damaged portion of the
neuron and they might help to repair the
overall process of
regeneration so let's look at the
Regeneration of new peripheral nervous
system neuron and how Swan cell is
important for that so Swan cell can
possibly do many things when when there
is a neuronal injury so here is a
neuronal injury so the distal part of
the neuronal injury would eventually be
degraded and would eventually be cleared
by the macro
phases later
on the Schwan cells would take important
role in terms of guiding the process so
here we can see there are de
differentiated Schwan cells which align
in a specific band-like fashion known as
bands of bangar and this particular for
this particular structure forms a
passage way where the axonal Sprouts can
grow and regenerate the neuron
again so this is how Swan cells help in
nervous regeneration so let's talk about
the swan cell uh development so the
Schwan cells are actually developed from
the neural crest cells so these Swan
cells uh have different stage of their
maturation one stage is known as the
immature uh Swan cell progenitor then
there is immature Swan cell and
eventually they form the mature Swan
cells so initially there are
interactions with the axons Loosely then
there is strong interaction with the
Basel lamina and Swan cell starts
wrapping around the axon and thereby
they get matured so each of these stages
of the Schwan cell can be discriminated
by via specific molecular markers now
when it comes to disease Swan cells are
really
important but before that let us talk
about and compare the Schwan cells with
oligodendrocytes oligodendrocytes are
also gal subtypes which are helping in
myelination in the central nervous
system it's important to note Schwan
cells are present in peripheral nervous
system and not in the central nervous
system so Schwan cells can one Schwan
cell can contact only a single axon
whereas olgod dendrite one particular
oligodendrocyte them also their origin
is different swanel is neural crest
derivative whereas oligodendrocytes are
generated from common neuronal
progenitors now let's talk about Schwan
cels from a context of gulan bar
syndrome this is an acute rapidly
Progressive demyelinative autoimmune
disorder of the peripheral nerves here
the peripheral nerves are affected due
to one antibody known as gm1 ganglioside
Auto antibody so immune system
mistakenly recognize the Swan Swan cell
proteins and produce Auto antibodies
against them which eventually damage
these Schwan cells and the myelination
so obviously that lead to neuropathies
so initially this particular damage lead
to weakness numbness tingling and all
the sensation starts from the leg and uh
goes up towards the upper part of the
body so this is reflected in the
electromyography recordings so there is
a decrease in nerve conduction velocity
why because the swan cells are affected
the insulation is now faulty so the
conduction of the nerve is
slower apart from gulan bar syndrome
there is other syndrome known as sharot
Merit too disease or CMT in this case
also
there there is a damage in the swan cell
due to a mutation so these are inherited
peripheral neuropathies where the
mutation most of the cases the mutation
happens in pmp22 gene present on
chromosome 17 this particular Gene
product help in formation of the myeline
so it's a component of myeline so when
it is mutated the overall myin Shear is
damaged this lead to plethora of
syndromes symptoms including muscle pain
cold feet especially the characteristic
curled feet atrophy of the muscles and
curled
fingers so that brings out the
importance of Schwan cells in various
context so this is a quick summary about
the Schwan cells and it function so I
hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
get notes and flash cards in our
Facebook page and our Instagram page
links are provided in the description
you can support our Channel using super
thanks you can pay via Paypal PTM or UPI
see you in next
[Music]
video